JOANNA SMITH: OK, hi.
Good morning, everybody.
I'm Joanna Smith, and here we're
going to talk about Idle Modes.
I know you're all really
excited and you definitely
don't hate these and you're
definitely not frustrated.
So this is going to be a very
pleasant experience for all
of us, right?
Right?
OK, great.
So the greatest thing about
the next, like, half hour,
45 minutes of your
life is you're
going to sit here
and listen to me
talk and not get
to say anything,
and then you're going to walk
out of the room thinking,
great.
I don't have to do anything.
I'm exactly at my status
quo from before the talk.
So definitely a productive
use of your time.
And the reason you're going
to want to listen to me--
you could read my
online bio if you want.
I don't really care--
but specifically, I've
been a Developer
Advocate for Android
and I've been working a lot
on trying to educate people
about best practices.
We have a lot of
resources out there
for you to learn how to use
an API when it's launched
or how it works,
but nobody's really
trying to teach people when to
choose an API or how to, like,
use multiple pieces together.
And so that's why
myself and Ian Lake,
who's speaking right after me,
launched Android Development
Patterns.
So we have a series of
videos and pro tips online
so that you can learn
how to bust bad behavior
and how to make your app better.
We also created the Advanced
Android App Development Udacity
Course.
So if you are trying
to tweak your skills
or work with something a
little more complicated,
or you want to have a whole
lesson on how widgets work,
we're your people.
And then the other
thing I wanted
to say about me personally
is I started learning Android
in February of 2014.
So I'm not even quite at two
years, and yet I'm up here,
you know, representing
our Engineering team,
trying to teach other
people about best behavior.
And I say that because
a lot of people
get really intimidated learning
a new language or a new skill
set or, you know, if you
come from a Java background,
Android's, you know, lifecycle
doesn't make a lot of sense
and it can be overwhelming,
especially when we
change everything every year.
And so I just want to let you
know, like, don't give up hope
or don't get frustrated.
Like, there's a lot
out there, but you
can be really exceptional
without understanding
everything back to
Froyo, basically.
OK.
So let's get started.
The reason that I'm here
today, specifically,
is because battery is one of the
most important things that we
need to talk about, both
from our side as providing
an operating system and from
your side as developers.
Right?
This is the biggest
problem in mobile.
People get so
frustrated about this.
They're constantly trying
to measure their battery
as a consumer or
figure out what's
eating all of their battery
or why their phone has
to be charged twice in a day.
Users hate this.
And then they hate
you because they
don't understand
what you're doing
or why you're coming
up on top all the time.
And then they hate us and they
want to get a whole new phone,
right?
So there's a lot of press
about battery, tons of studies
that you can find just
from any kind of search
on your favorite web
engine, and it's a problem
that everybody wants to solve.
But the problem is, like, when
somebody tries to give you
blanket advice, they'll
tell you things like,
just don't have
lingering services
and don't do background
services and don't use memory
and basically don't be
an app, when the truth is
you want all of those things.
A device naturally will
launch an activity,
and that activity should be
using background services.
One of the most important
things to keep in mind
when building an app is
that we call our main thread
the UI thread for a reason.
Everything that you do there
affects what the users see,
and if you hang, if you
miss your frame rate,
they're going to
uninstall you because they
think you're janky.
They don't realize that
you missed your framework
because you're
working really hard.
And we can't educate
users, so you just
have to, like, fake it
till you make it, right?
So my point here is that
background services aren't bad.
What's bad is when every
app has their own background
service over time
triggering willy-nilly.
We need to coalesce
these together so
that we can create a good
experience for the battery.
Because if you only use
the radio twice in a day,
but you use it separate
from everybody else,
the radio never gets a break.
And that's not good for network,
that's not good for the device.
And so because we can't
really teach people
how to do this work
with other apps,
because you don't have
insight into other apps,
we're going to force you into
my favorite mental model.
And that's what Doze is for.
So get comfortable
with this image.
I know it's really complicated
and hard to remember,
and you're not going to
see it again, so, you know,
you really have to work
hard, but the idea here
is over time I want every
app's background job and sync
to line up in batches.
Because then we can
turn the radio on once.
It doesn't particularly
matter for most apps
if their sync happens
at 6:00 PM or 8:00 PM,
so let's take advantage
of that flexibility.
And that's what Doze is for.
So we'll go over that first.
Doze was introduced
in Marshmallow,
but it doesn't
really matter what
API you're targeting
because Doze is going
to affect every
Marshmallow device,
even if you're still
rockin' that Lollipop.
OK.
So you have to get understanding
[INAUDIBLE] of this,
because you have no control over
what device your users have,
right?
So you would think that with
something as big as Doze,
we'd have a lot of goals for it.
But the truth is,
we only have one.
We want to preserve the
user's battery life.
That's our one goal here.
We want to create a better
user experience by making sure
that when the user puts their
tablet down and, like, goes off
to Cabo for a week, they come
back, pick their tablet up,
and it's still alive.
They weren't using
it, so why did it die?
Like, that doesn't
make any sense,
and so we're here for that.
But the truth is, like I
said, we can't really, like,
get you to work kindly
with other apps,
because that's not really,
like, a possible situation here.
So we forced you, and people
don't really like that.
And that's why there's
a lot of, you know,
very kind comments on
Twitter that definitely
aren't frustrating at all.
And so before we can really
get into, like, more of the
why here, I need to explain my
goal for you, which is this.
You aren't as important
as you probably
think your app is,
because as a developer,
your mind is in the zone of
thinking about your app all day
long.
You kind of go to sleep
thinking about that problem
you want to fix, and you wake
up thinking, oh, gosh, no.
This bugged, too.
Like, it never leaves your head.
Whereas with your user, they're
not going to use it all day,
every day, right?
And you need to come to terms
with that as a developer.
So my best example of
this is a success metric.
So our fearless
leader is Larry Page.
He's pretty great.
And he defines success inside of
Google by a toothbrush metric.
So if your product
is used twice a day
for about a minute
each time, you
are insanely successful
and worth investing, like,
a quarter of Google's
resources in.
Like, that is
something that's going
to hit home and be great
and change the world.
So that's two
minutes a day, right?
Which means that
there are 23 hours
and 58 minutes
that the user isn't
using your app or your
product, and you're still
a grand success that
Alphabet would invest in.
Right?
Like, that's perspective, right?
And it's hard to keep that
in mind when all you do
is create your app.
So 23 hours and 58 minutes.
You have to be willing to
recognize that, like, users
exist outside of you
for all of that time
and you can be a little bit
more flexible about when exactly
your background
sync is happening.
That being said, let's go
into exactly what Doze is.
Doze is when your
device is fully "idle,"
but, like, not really
sure what that means.
So what happens in Doze mode?
First, network
access is suspended.
The whole point here is we
don't want the radio going off.
We don't want it going
off every five minutes,
we don't want it going
off every 15 minutes,
we want to do this in a
controlled setting when we can.
So network is off.
Like, you're just going
to have to deal with that.
The second is we don't
care about your wake logs.
The device isn't being
used, therefore you really
shouldn't be doing anything.
Like, this isn't I'm going
to send notifications
to get the user's attention.
This is they're not
even in the room.
Like, it's not happening.
They don't care
about the device.
You shouldn't care either.
So along that same vein,
all your alarms are delayed.
And we understand that alarms
are a great way for you
to control the flow of
your app, so we're not
deleting your alarms, we're
not dropping your alarms,
we're just going
to hold them off
until the Doze mode is over,
and then they'll all trigger
and you can react to each
one the way you normally
would in a nice batch.
And then the most
important part.
Syncs and jobs are
not going to run.
But this is the same deal.
We aren't deleting your
background jobs and syncs.
We're not making sure
your app doesn't ever
get a chance to exist.
We're just controlling when
they're going to happen,
which is when the
device is active.
We also-- I have to mention--
have these periodic maintenance
windows that I'll go
into further detail,
so that prolonged Doze periods
still get a chance for you
to run periodic updates
at least once a day.
OK, so then now that you're
all worried and you're like,
wow, they hate us and
my app's going to die,
let me tell you how we
even get into Doze mode
and why it still doesn't
matter for your app.
Doze is going to be triggered
when the device is not
charging, right?
Because we care about battery.
So if we're plugged in, we
don't care about any of this.
We're not at risk, we're not
worried, we're not concerned.
There's power coming
from somewhere.
So the device is not
charging, it's out there
draining the battery, and the
screen has been turned off.
So probably they're
not interacting.
But most importantly,
it's not moving.
There's a difference
between having your phone
in your pocket and it going
idle, which would be awful
when you need to
navigate somewhere,
and having it down
on the counter
as you come up here to give an
hour-long presentation, right?
One of them, I'm going to
respond to a text message.
And the other one, probably not.
OK.
So these three states.
We've really put a lot
of thought into this,
and you'll see why as I
continue to talk to you.
So let's take a look
at this beautiful image
that you probably recognize from
our documentation about Doze,
because you totally
read all of our docs
and you're really
excited about it.
This is an estimation of, like,
a timeline of how Doze works.
We have this nice long period if
we're idle, right, at the end,
and these nice orange bars which
represent those maintenance
windows that you'll start
to understand later on.
And then we have these crazy
spikes at the beginning.
And all those crazy spikes
represent normal usage
of the device, and
that's the period
when the user is
using it and we're
trying to determine if
we have reached idle mode
and if we're there yet,
and, like, how confident we
are that we really
should be idle right now.
So normal usage, which
if it happened all day,
would drain the
battery in, like, what?
Hours?
OK.
So the reason we have this nice
long period of normal usage
even after we might have
started thinking about Doze
is because we want to hit
that confidence level.
And to do that, we have States.
So we don't just jump
straight from Active to Idle,
we walk ourselves into it.
And we do that with a Device
Idle Controller Class.
So this class was introduced
in the Marshmallow code,
it's pretty fantastic,
and it's part of the AOSP.
So you can read about it and
figure out what's going on
and understand everything on
your own, or you can trust me,
or you can find someone
else who wrote a blog on it
and read their blog.
OK.
So there are several states.
The first and easiest
is Active, right?
Because if we're Active, then
we know that everything's
working properly
and, like, they're
using their device
and your app is
going to run exactly as
expected and that's just great.
Then we hit
Inactive, and this is
when we've noticed
that the screen is off
and the device isn't moving and
all those conditions for Doze
have been met, but, like, we
don't really know why yet.
We're just like, OK, great.
We're not Active.
We're just chill with this.
And then comes an
Idle Pending State,
which is, OK, we weren't Active.
It's been a period of time.
We're still not Active.
Let's-- one vote of confidence.
Like, we're getting
close to there.
And we have to go through this
before we can ever even get
to our Idle State.
Right?
And the beautiful
thing about this
is you can read the
class in the AOSP,
and you can see
how we get there.
And it's really easy because
Device Idle Controller
has an Alarm Manager that
triggers its own alarm so
that it can track
its own progress.
And so we wait about 30
minutes between each alarm
to see have we
gotten out of this?
Like, are we good?
Like, did something happen?
Are we moving?
Like, is there some
new foreground service?
Like, what's going on?
And then we use those
half-hour periods to see, like,
do we need to back up?
Or do we move forward?
So there's a very long
time to be comfortable
if the user's really
not interested
before we get to idle.
And that way, you can
trust our Comfort Levels.
You can know if they're
comfortable that the user's not
coming, I can be comfortable
the user's not coming,
and I don't have
to panic and think
my app is going to be ignored.
Because we care about
our developers, even when
you're upset with us.
OK.
There's also a state
called Idle Maintenance.
And this one's really
cool because this
is that Maintenance
window that we get to.
So we have a really
long Doze period.
We understand that you
probably want to, like,
have updated information for
whenever the user comes back,
so we let you run your jobs
and syncs all in a batch
to get to our beautiful
timeline of our mental model
that you definitely
memorized even
though it was so complicated.
And we're going to be able to
batch run all these jobs so
that you're up-to-date when we
finally get out of Idle Mode.
OK.
So those are Batch Windows.
That's what that Idle
Maintenance means,
these nice orange,
thick spikes later on.
And your Mental Model,
because I've got it.
Right?
You all forgot it?
The super complicated
Mental Model
of what we're trying
to get over time
is these batch syncs and jobs
from different activities.
So this is our ideal world.
And you definitely
won't see this again, so
memorize it this time.
Now, all of those
being said, you
want to know how these
states work, right?
Like, you want to see for
sure that you can trust us.
And we've made this
super cool ADB service
that you can step your app into
them and see what's going on.
And it's super easy to run.
You just need a Marshmallow
device or emulator,
your app needs to be running,
and then you need to tell the,
you know, ADB, like,
unplug so we're
outside of the charging mode.
And then Dump Sys,
you've probably
seen before, it's
a binary that let's
you call other services by name.
And then Device Idle,
that's your new service.
And you can step through each
state, see what's going on,
or you can ask for help.
With any other, like, command
line service, it's so easy.
It's super easy to use.
And you can test your code
to be like, OK, great.
They weren't lying.
And you can also, you
know, look for surprises
to see whether or not we
really did mess you up
and then you can go on Twitter
and yell at me some more.
OK.
So how do you get
out of Doze mode?
Well, it exits when
pretty much the reverse
of everything else that
caused us to enter happens.
When we plug it
in, so everything
gets released from Doze
mode because battery's
totally safe now.
Or we pick the device up
because the user has come back
and they want to
see what's going on.
Or, and this is the cool one,
an alarm is going to go off.
And I don't mean an
alarm like Alarm Manager,
because now you're
wondering if I lied before,
and you're like, wait.
You said you don't
listen to those.
I mean, like, an alarm.
Like, I set my alarm
clock and I need to, like,
remember to get back to work by,
like, the time for my meeting,
otherwise I'm going
to get in trouble.
Or I'm going to miss my
doctor's appointment.
Like, users need alarms.
So what we do is when we have an
alarm clock pending by our app
or one of your
apps, like something
that's registered
as an alarm, then we
wake up from Doze
mode a little bit
before, everybody runs their
sync, then the alarm goes off,
the user wakes up
from their nap and can
see all of their updated
news, weather, and traffic.
Right?
Look how smart we were?
See?
We hear you guys.
You just, you know, are
still a little upset.
So it's OK.
So how do you not do anything?
Well, you know, your app
should work like I told you.
Nothing gets dropped,
nothing gets delayed,
nothing gets deleted.
So it's all, like, maybe
a couple of hours off,
but the user didn't notice
and you won't notice, right?
Like, everything's good.
But if you have something
special, you can adapt.
Right?
A couple simple things that
you probably don't need to do,
but I'm going to tell you
how to do them anyway.
So the first is
you need to think
about your app's architecture.
You need to understand
what it's doing
and what it's expecting,
because if you have something
kind of weird, like your
server relies on your client
to check in every day at
6:00 PM for an update, then
probably that's not going to
be great because if you miss
that because you're in
Doze mode at 6:00 PM,
then your server's
going to panic.
But then again, you shouldn't
be doing that anyway.
So that's on you.
And you should use
downstream messaging.
This is just a
general best practice.
That way your client is always
the one reacting instead
of each server.
But if you're using downstream
messaging, and specifically
Google Cloud Messaging, which
you should be using anyway,
and I can tell you
about that later,
then you can add a
High Priority Tag.
And this is great,
because anything
with a high priority,
the system will receive
and they'll be able
to say, OK, great.
Temporary wake up for the app.
They can react to this
high priority message
and be able to
respond appropriately
in case it actually is something
important, like, you know,
a text message if you're,
like, a messaging app.
Because something from
your mom you might actually
want to work out here.
Now people are probably going
to think, this is great,
I'll add high priority
to every message I send.
And I say, you suck and you're
ruining the whole process.
So please don't do that.
Great anecdote for
you to keep in mind.
If it's a high
priority, then it's
worth getting the
user's attention, right?
Which means stopping a
developer for a minute--
and think about
your user self-- are
you going to get up
out of that chair,
cross to that side of the
room, pick your phone up
off the table and
look at it and groan?
Or be like, OK, good.
Nice to know.
Because if you have to
walk all the way over there
to look at a notification
and it's just something
about, like, you got a hundred
new points in your game,
you're going to be really
frustrated with that app
and probably
uninstall it, right?
But if you walk over there
because your mom wants
to know what kind of pie
you want for Thanksgiving
and she's baking it tonight,
then that's important.
That's super important, right?
So there's your method to
tell is it high priority?
Do I walk across the
room and I'm upset?
And you as
developers, you really
don't want to get up
from your computer
and stop coding, right?
That's your metric.
And if you can
keep that in mind,
you're going to be
super successful.
OK.
So the other thing
you can do is--
I kind of lied when I said we
ignore all of the Alarm Manager
alarms.
We actually have
these exceptions.
Your Set and your
Set Exact methods
have a new counterpart called
Set And Allow While Idle or Set
Exact And Allow While
Idle, which-- surprise,
surprise-- allows the
alarm to go off while we're
in an Idle Mode, right?
Super great naming.
OK.
So these are really
great if you actually do
have something time critical.
Like, maybe you want
your calendar app
or, like, you're going
to trigger a notification
in advance of some event that
is really important to the user
and they can't miss that.
So we give you this opportunity.
Wake up your app a little.
You still don't
have network access
and you still can't run
your background services,
but you can wake up, react,
produce a notification,
trigger a sound, everything
that the user would care about.
So as far as the user can tell
and as far as you can tell,
there's no change
in app behavior,
but you're still able to do
and accomplish everything
you want, and we're still
able to preserve our battery.
So the other thing
to know about these
is you can't just go willy-nilly
changing every alarm you have,
because if you're one of
those apps that has, like,
an alarm going off
every two minutes,
this isn't going to help you
because we've throttled these.
Sorry.
Going to have to live it it.
We care about battery.
So one alarm will go off
in a 15-minute period.
So if you trigger two
right after each other
or, like, in a
five-minute window,
there's going to be a 15-minute
delay before the second one
triggers.
Which actually is fine.
Most apps won't affect this.
Like, a calendar event
notification and 15 minutes
before and, like, at the
moment, that's about right.
Two minutes before
and one minute before,
that's a little spammy.
So, again, you really
shouldn't have to change much
but maybe add a
couple of characters.
And these methods
aren't any different.
The only thing that changes
in creating the whole alarm,
getting it an instance,
actually setting it,
is these extra And Allow
While Idle letters.
That's the only difference.
All of the parameters
are exactly the same.
All of you wake up and timing,
everything is exactly the same.
The method behaves
exactly the same,
but our system will
acknowledge that you
have something important
and we'll give you
the chance to act on that.
Because, believe it or
not, we don't hate you.
Right?
Like, we're trying to do
the best thing for the user,
and since nobody can
really listen to us,
we're going to force you to
do it with us, but in a really
kind way.
OK.
And then the other thing you
might want to do to adapt
is to test your app.
But seriously, you should
have been doing this anyway,
so this isn't actually
adding to your to do list.
So at most, you've got, like,
two halves of a step to do.
Like, a high priority
and And Allow While Idle.
That's not really
that much work,
and you could have done it
while you were listening to me
and already be done.
So you can still
leave the room not
having changed anything, right?
Everybody's calm?
Everybody's good?
OK.
I'm also supposed to
mention that we technically
have a whitelist,
but I'm supposed
to remind you that you
probably don't qualify for it.
And you need to be really
careful about trying to use it
because we have a very, very
few special use cases that
are spelled out in
our documentation
and are subjected to a Play
store developer policy.
And it's really probably
not applicable to you,
because we want to get to
this beautiful mental model
that I told you to
memorize, right?
And we can't do that
if we have one or two
apps exempted from that that
are constantly using the radio.
It undermines the
entire process.
So they're being really kind
of mean about the whitelist.
But you don't need it anyway,
because I already convinced you
that your app isn't going to be
destroyed by Doze mode, right?
Like, nobody's scared anymore.
Right?
You might still be angry,
but you can Tweet at me,
and that's fine.
I'll take it.
So let's shift gears and
we'll talk about App Standby.
It's kind of Doze's cousin.
It was also introduced
in Marshmallow.
And it's also going to
affect you no matter
what you're targeting, because
it affects every Marshmallow
device.
Now, the cool thing
about App Standby
is it has the exact
same goals as Doze does.
It's really easy to remember.
We just care about the battery.
We care about a
beautiful user experience
and making sure that we
can get that at all times.
Because this is that mental
model that you totally
forgot by now, right?
Because it's so complicated.
Over time, we want
every background thing
to be happening in batches.
And if the user's still
using their device actively,
we never get into
Doze mode, we still
want to be able to
optimize for them.
So we've done is we've made
a slight comparison, which
stands out in the sense
that it affects apps.
It doesn't affect
the whole device.
The device is still functional.
But if an app hasn't
been used in a while,
then we're going
to kind of decrease
when that app has access.
[INAUDIBLE] we're trying to
optimize all of the quiet ones.
OK.
So other things you want to
know about the difference
before we go into this
is that we're definitely
restricting network access,
because we care about that.
Except now we're doing
it on the app level
instead of on the device level.
We're still delaying
all your jobs and syncs.
They'll get their chance.
I promise they'll
get their chance,
but it's going to be
in a controlled way.
We're going honor
wake locks, though.
We're going to, like,
adhere to your wake clocks,
respect your wake
locks, and we're
going to respect your
alarms from Alarm Manager.
And these two things
at the end, that's
what's going to have
all of the difference,
because App Standby is triggered
differently than Doze is.
So it's triggered when, again,
the user's not using your app.
So this is a similar
idea to the device,
except they just aren't
opening your app.
They haven't opened
it all month.
They're not really
that interested in it.
And, I'm sorry, like, not
every app is used every day.
Remember the toothbrush test.
OK.
Then the other thing
is that maybe you
don't have any active activities
or foreground services.
Like, nothing in the
foreground is running.
If you're streaming
music, like, we
get that, that that's
kind of important,
and, like, they're not
interacting with your app,
but they're listening to it for
the whole course of the party.
It shouldn't cut
out in the middle.
So foreground services
and activities,
those are respected.
And even more than that,
we respect your foreground
services and activities if they
were launched by another app.
It doesn't have to be
launched by the user,
but if your, you know,
app behaves in response
to another app, we
respect that, too.
Anything in the
foreground is safe.
But this is where our
differences matter.
There are no pending
notifications in the lock tray
or on the lock screen.
Sorry, notification
tray or the lock screen.
Which means that you actually
have this really cool way
of getting yourself
out of App Standby
when it matters to your app.
So let's talk about
how to do that.
So App Standby is going to end
when, you know, the user wants
to use your app.
That's a very
clear signal to us.
They want to interact
with you, you're
going to interact with them.
Or the device is plugged
in, because, again, we're
doing all of this for battery.
So if we're plugged into the
wall, everything is free.
Everything is released
from App Standy, Doze ends.
Like, everything
is free to behave
as they want as long as
we have power coming.
But the most important is
that maybe your Alarm Manager
set an alarm, and that
alarm is going to go off.
And then because
the alarm went off,
you're going to do some sort
of work in response to that
and you're going to create
a notification to the user
that something's up-to-date.
Maybe at 6:00 PM
there are new levels
for their game available.
Or maybe, you know, like,
there's new information
that you want to present.
So anything that would be worthy
of creating a notification,
that's fine.
Like, you can behave
as you normally
would in response to a time
or, like, maybe new information
or some sort of trigger
or, like, you just
have some ads you want
to display so you bring
your user back into your app.
Like, we get it.
You have to monetize.
But all of that means that
you can create a notification,
present it to the user,
which, again, you're
getting their attention.
So remember the walk
across the room test.
But as soon as you
do that, you're
released from App Standby,
because if you have a pending
notification, the
user is probably
going to come your way
pretty soon, right?
Like, they're, like,
going to look at that
and be like, oh, yeah.
I need to interact with you.
So we respect that that means
that you don't need to be able
right now, and you probably
need to have access
to, like, your background
services or your syncs
or the network so you can be
ready when they open your app.
See?
We get you.
You don't think we get you,
but we thought really hard
about our developers.
I promise.
OK.
So see this?
This beautiful mental
model that you definitely
forgot because I've
only showed it to you,
like, four times already?
We want to get to this
ideal world with batching.
And so what we did is we
created App Standby, like,
we bothered with
this whole effort of,
like, making you upset with us
so you Tweet at us that you're
mad and then we have to explain
to you, like, why it's OK.
We went through all
of this because we
can achieve this mental model
with App Standby offering
periodic maintenance windows.
So maybe your app
isn't used every day.
Maybe you're like a
once-a-month kind of app.
That's fine, but you
still need to be ready
when they open your
app, because they're
going to come back
to you at some point.
Right?
So we guarantee you
a maintenance window
at least once a day,
if not more often.
So that even if it's been 20
days since you've been used,
you're ready and
you're up-to-date
and you're, at most, just
a couple hours behind
in information.
Right?
So a guaranteed periodic
maintenance window
for every app in App Standby
means they all run together
with one use of the radio.
That is a huge
achievement for battery.
And so sorry if
you don't like it,
but it's going to work really
well for your app, I promise.
And it's great for
our users, which
means it's going to be great for
you and the 18 different phones
and tablets you
have in your house.
Right?
OK.
So an anecdote about
why we did this.
Like, let's consider
a successful app
that you might not use every
day, like a movie streaming app
or like a movie purchase
and ticketing app.
These kinds of things
you don't use every day.
You probably wait until
you're in the car,
like, stuck like you're still a
seven-year-old in the back seat
while your parents drive
to your grandparents' house
for Thanksgiving.
Which will probably happen what?
Tomorrow?
Like, that's a
situation nobody wants
to be in, especially
as an adult.
So you're going to pull out your
phone while everybody else is
arguing and start, like,
watching, you know,
whatever streaming
you're in the middle of,
and you probably haven't
used it since like, what?
October?
And so the difference is when
you're dealing with something
like digital content, you need
to make sure that everything
is up-to-date, like
new information,
new shows, new
movies, are all there
and available on the list.
Or, more importantly,
that, like,
the licenses for any digital
content that was purchased
have been refreshed.
Because otherwise the app has
to legally delete it, right?
So those like once
a day guaranteed
maintenance windows
means that you're always
ready in any kind of situation
no matter what your app's use
case is, right?
So we thought long and hard.
I really promise.
And if you don't believe me,
you can throw any use case
that you want at
me, and I'll try
to come up with a good answer.
OK.
But this is our goal.
Everyone agrees that, like,
we're getting to our goal.
So you're starting to see
why we had a good reason
and you only hate
me, like, 20% now.
OK.
So how do you adapt
to App Standby?
Because you have no
control over this
and you don't know when you're
an App Standby and that's
kind of scary.
I get that.
Right?
So, again, you shouldn't
have to do anything, right?
Your alarms are honored,
your wake locks are honored,
and your jobs and syncs
will run at least once
a day, which means you'll
have network access at least
once a day.
So, like, you're good
until you're being used.
But if something does
come up, we get that.
So, hello GCM.
It's your best friend, right?
Like, you're totally
convinced that you
love downstream messaging
with our super great service,
and the high priority stance.
Any message that comes through
to the system with a High Party
tag will mean that your app
is given a temporary reprieve
from Idle Mode to react to that.
And so if that reaction includes
a notification that you create,
great.
You're out of Idle Mode.
But if it's just something
that you need to do to,
like, speak with your
server, then great.
You're still in Idle Mode,
but at least you're informed.
Your client can rely on
all your communication
from your server
that's time sensitive.
And anything that's
not time sensitive
is just held for you until
your maintenance window.
So no matter what, you're not
missing anything important.
Like, you're good.
You guys are good to go.
You're going to be great.
It's going to be awesome.
OK.
So now you've been
listening to me for awhile,
and you're probably confused.
You're like, wait.
What I do?
Because my app use case has
totally not been talked about.
And, like, you really shouldn't
have done this Idle Mode
in the first place, you guys.
Like, battery was totally fine.
OK.
Well, that's not true.
And this is happening.
It's done.
It's mandatory.
Any device on Marshmallow, so
time to live in our new world.
I know you're really excited and
you're not frustrated at all.
But what you actually need
to do here is believe us.
This Mental Model.
See, you totally forgot it
so I put it back up here
because it's so complicated.
Over time, we want
everything done in a batch.
We want to turn the
radio on only maybe,
like, a couple times a day
if that device isn't used.
Or only, like, once a day
if it's being used while,
like, everyone else is,
like, doing their job sync.
And we just want to do
one batch for all of that.
Like, let the user
have some control here.
And remember, understand
when you are important
and when you are not
as far as a life.
A day in a life goes.
So one app trying to
be an exception to this
undermines the
whole process, which
is why this is now mandatory
and forced on all of you
because that's the only
way we can achieve success.
And you're totally going
to forgive us because I'm
really great, and you like me.
OK.
But, again, your to
do list here basically
includes rethinking some stuff.
You need to understand
what has changed.
Wake locks and alarms.
Their behavior may or may
not be trustworthy depending
on whether you're in Doze mode.
Your alarms will trigger,
but maybe not exactly
right on the moment, right?
In App Standby, you can
still count on these.
But, again, the
behavior has shifted
so that changes the way
you think about some
of the assumptions you
made in your architecture.
And then your jobs
and your syncs
might happen a
couple hours late,
and that has to be OK with you.
Like, you need to make
sure that your system is
able to react to that.
So this is what's changed,
but at the same time,
nothing has actually changed,
because, like I said,
we're not deleting
your jobs and syncs,
they're just a couple hours
late, which for most apps
is not a noticeable difference
because most apps use
downstream messaging and
they rely on the client
to speak to the
server to get updates
and then the
server's probably not
expecting, like, a one specific
moment of the day check-in.
So you're probably OK.
I guarantee you that
you're probably OK.
But let's revisit
our to do list.
Think about your app
architecture, right?
Update time-critical
alarms that actually matter
with in And Allow While Idle.
It's the only change.
It's like, what?
40 characters in your
whole codebase probably.
You're great.
Like, totally easy.
You might not even have to.
Add high priority flags
to any downstream messages
through GCM, which technically
isn't an Android change so you
can still kind of
chalk that up to, like,
a server-level change.
So again, your to do list
is basically nothing.
But then the most
important thing
is you just need
to test your app.
You need to walk through what's
going on in your application,
step through with
our ADB service,
see what the behavior
is getting into
and out of the Idle modes,
and most importantly,
make sure that you
aren't surprised.
Because if you're surprised
by some sort of behavior,
something that doesn't
happen when it should
or something that happens when
it shouldn't, then your user
is going to be surprised, and
surprised users uninstall apps
because they don't
understand what's happening
and then they think that you're
stealing their information
or training their battery.
You don't want to be that app.
OK.
And then when
you've done all this
and you found something that
you don't like, you just repeat.
See?
Test your app.
You notice how this
is kind of just
your development flow normally?
So there really
isn't a change, which
is why I'm convincing
you that you can walk out
of the room being
like, OK, good.
Status quo.
No difference.
Right?
You don't seem like
you're convinced,
but here's the, again,
how to test your app.
What you've got here are two
super, super sweet ADB services
that we created with
Marshmallow that I
told you step through Doze
mode or super even easier
than that is the set Inactive
Service for App Standby you
just said True or False.
Set Inactive, let's
see what goes on.
Set Inactive False.
OK, great.
We're out of it.
Let's see what happens now.
You also want to test your
actions and look for surprises.
And if you're not
surprised, then you
can just call it
a week on Tuesday
and go home and be
like, turkey time.
And if you are surprised,
you can be like crap.
I'm going to go on Twitter
and yell at that girl.
But hopefully, your apps
are going to be surviving
and they're going to be fine.
And if they don't, that's OK.
You can, like I said,
come and yell at me.
This is how you find
me on G+ or on Twitter.
And if you have a use case that
actually does kind of stand
out, I will go and
I will fight for you
to our PM to see, like, what
his expected reaction was.
But for the most part, every
app has a solution here,
and it's not that difficult.
So this is my whole
30 minute talk.
That's 15 minutes while
I'll be standing right here
and you can come
say your mean things
or ask me your really
good questions.
But I hope you guys have a great
day, and thanks for listening.